ya 30 ans jour pour jour le 21 décembre
1991 après des mois de déliquescence la
dissolution officielle de l'urss alma
ata au kazakhstan de cette décomposition
naquit une nouvelle carte delà de cette
région du monde un géant la russie et à
terme une quinzaine d'autres républiques
parmi lesquelles l'ukraine l'ukraine on
vous retrouve gulliver crack bonjour
gulliver désacord alma alta est née la
communauté des états indépendants qui a
quitté l'ukraine depuis kiev a choisi
une trajectoire éloignée de celle que
lui proposait moscou à l'époque
surtout l'ukraine est resté une
démocratie pendant les années 90 les
trajectoires de l'ukraine et la russie
étaient similaires il y a eu un passage
très rapide au capitalisme ce qui a fait
que les atouts de l'état ont été vendus
et des oligarques ont pris le contrôle
de beaucoup d'entreprises et sont
devenus très riches et ont acquis un
contrôle politique mais dont le début
des années 2000 vladimir poutine a plus
ou moins condamné les oligarques russes
soit alex il soit à le soutenir lui
alors qu en ukraine il y a toujours eu
une pluralité d'oligarques ce qui a fait
qu'il y a eu une rivalité entre
différents camps politiques et qui a en
quelque sorte préserver la démocratie en
ukraine même si bien sûr c'est une
démocratie imparfaite et les ukrainiens
ont voté pour des gouvernements pro
occidental à presque toutes les
élections il y a eu en 2004 une
tentative de faire élire victor
ianoukovitch qui était plutôt pro-russe
c'était le candidat préféré de vladimir
poutine mais ils ont eu recours à la
fraude les ukrainiens ont manifesté
c'était la révolution orange et après il
y a eu un gouvernement pro européen mais
en 2010 victor ianoukovitch a à gagner
plus ou moins légitimement une élection
est donc l'ukraine commencé à nouveau à
avoir un trajectoire plus proche de
celui de moscou mais victor ianoukovitch
avait tout de même promis à l'électorat
de signer un accord d'association avec
l'union européenne
sinon je pense que il pensait qu'il
n'aurait pas pu être élu et compte au
final il n'a pas signé cet accord encore
une fois
les ukrainiens ont manifesté et victor
ianoukovitch a été chassé du pouvoir et
donc depuis 2014 l'ukraine a un
gouvernement pro européen et c'est le
fait de la démocratie en ukraine même si
bien sûr il y à une minorité très
importante qui reste plutôt sympathique
à la russie mais on a l'impression que
c'est une partie de la population qui
s'en va en diminuant surtout à cause de
l'agression de la russie avec l'annexion
de la crimée et la guerre qui continue
dans l'est du pays donc même si vous
avez en ukraine encore des endroits où
les pro russes sont probablement
majoritaire la ville d'odessa portuaire
dans le sud du pays on est un exemple
important on a maintenant depuis 2014
le sentiment que les pro européens les
pro occidentaux se sont installés pour
la durée dans le parlement ukrainien
dont le gouvernement ukrainien
voilà vous parler de ces éléments pro
russe en ukraine gulliver ce qui se
passe en ce moment à la frontière est de
l'ukraine et ce qui suscite d'ailleurs
beaucoup de tensions internationales
c'est le signe que moscou n'a jamais
renoncé non plus à garder à l'ukraine
dans sa au moins dans sa sphère d
influence
ça c'est vraiment la question qu'on se
pose en ukraine jusqu'où poutine veut
aller qu'est ce que c'est vraiment à
quoi il n'a jamais renoncé est ce que
pour lui c'est vraiment le contrôle de
l'ukraine l' influence déterminante de
la russie sur l'ukraine qu'il veut
rétablir ou est ce que c'est juste une
question de sécurité des garanties que
l'ukraine ne rentre pas par exemple dans
l'otan si on pense que c'est la première
option et que vladimir poutine pense que
c'est la mission si vous voulez de sa
présidence était rétablir le contrôle de
la régie sur l'ukraine si vladimir
poutine est convaincu que cette partie
de l'ukraine pied pour russe pourrait
redevenir majoritaire alors il y a de
quoi s'inquiéter parce que si vladimir
poutine pense que cela ne se passera pas
par la voie électorale ou par la demo de
la diplomatie si on pense qu'il a tiré
la conclusion que
l'option militaire est la seule option
pour rétablir ce contrôle et que c'est
vraiment cela qu'il veut faire alors là
ça fait un peu froid dans le dos si on
habite en ukraine et si les ukrainiens
avaient accueilli ces inquiétudes des
états unis les les troupes russes à la
frontière assez calmement ces dernières
semaines en disant que poutine ne
prendrai jamais un tel risque les
conséquences pour la russie négatif
serait trop importante alors là
maintenant avec la rhétorique terrus ces
derniers jours on commence à penser mais
peut-être que il est réellement prêts à
prendre ce risque parce que c'est si
important pour lui de l'hiver craag à
kiev merci beaucoup gulliver la suite
toute la journée sur france 24 de votre
journée spéciale consacrée aux 30 ans de
la dissolution de l'urss